what's mindfulness
so published on that as well um and i
practice i've been practicing many forms
of mindfulness and ecology of practices
since 1991 so i both have
practitioners knowledge and i also study
it scientifically i think i'm pretty
sure i was the first person to
academically talk about mindfulness at
the university of toronto within a
classroom setting like lecturing on it
so this is a topic that a lot of people
have recently become very interested in
think about
so from that
from the early days how do you think
about what it is
i've critiqued the sort of standard
definitions being you know aware of the
present moment without judgment and
because i think they're they're they're
flawed um and if you want to get into
the detail of why we can but this is how
i want to explain it to you
and it also points to the fact of why
you need an ecology of mindfulness
practices you shouldn't equate
mindfulness with meditation i think
that's a primary mistake when you say
ecology what do you mean by the way like
so lots of many different
variants no so what i mean by ecology is
exactly what you have in an ecology you
have a dynamical system in which there
are checks and balances on each other
right and i'll get to that with this
about mindfulness so i'll make that
connection if you allow me
so we're always framing we've been
talking about that right and
for those of you who are not on youtube
at this podcast i wear glasses and i'm
now sort of putting my my my my fingers
and thumb around the l the frames of my
glasses so this is my frame and i and my
lenses right and that frame
the frame holds a lens and i'm seeing
through it in both senses beyond and by
means of it
so right now my glasses are transparent
to me i want to use that as a strong
analogy for my mental framing okay now
sometimes this is what you do in
meditation i would argue
you step back from looking through your
frame and you look at them i'm taking my
glasses off right now and i'm looking at
them why might i do that to see if
there's something in the lenses that is
distorting
right causing me to right now if i just
did that that could be helpful
but how do i know if i've actually
corrected
the change i made to my lenses
what do i need to do i need to put my
glasses on and see if i can now see more
clearly and deeply than i could before
meditation is this stepping back and
looking at
contemplation is
that looking through and they're
different kinds of practices the fact
that we treat them as synonyms is a deep
mistake the word contemplation has
temple in it in latin contemplation
means to look up to the sky it's it's a
translation of the greek word theoria
which we get our word theory from it's
to look deeply into things meditation is
more about
having to do with reflecting upon
standing back and looking at
mindfulness includes both
it includes your ability
to break away from an inappropriate
frame
and the ability to make a new frame
that's what actually happens in insight
you have to both break an inappropriate
frame and make see
realize a new frame this is why
mindfulness enhances insight both ways
by the way meditative practices
and also contemplative practices
so mindfulness is frame
awareness
that can be appropriated in order to
improve your capacities for insight and
self-regulation
now i'm inexperienced with meditation
sort of the practic the rigorous
practice and the science meditation
but you know i've uh talked to people
who
uh
seriously as a science study
psychedelics
and they often talk about
the really important thing is the sort
of the
integration back so the contemplation
step yeah so if you
it's not just the actual things you see
on psychedelics or the actual journey of
where your mind goes on psychedelics
it's also the integrating that into
the new perspective that you take on
life
right exactly you you really nicely
described so meditation is the in that
metaphors is the psychedelic journey uh
to a different mind state and
contemplation is the
the return back to reality how you
integrate that into a new world
view and mindfulness is the whole
process those right so if you if you if
you just did
contemplation you could suffer from
inflation and projective fantasy
if you just do meditation you can suffer
from withdrawal spiritual bypassing
avoiding reality they act they they need
each other you have to cycle between
them it's like what i talked about
earlier when i talked about the opponent
processing within the autonomic nervous
system or the opponent processing at
work and attention and that's what i
mean by an ecology of practices you need
both
neither one is a panacea you need them
in this opponent processing acting as
checks and balance on each other
you